[Musique]
le
non
[Musique]
aucune
[Musique]
oui d'ailleurs voilà qui est bien est ce
quelque chose de nouveau
oui c'est une sérénade que je lui ai
fait composé ici
en attendant que notre homme plus
d'éveiller peut-on voir ce que c'est
vous allez sans attendre avec le
dialogue quand il viendra y notament la
guerre nos occupations à vous et à moi
ne sont pas petit maintenant il est vrai
nous avons trouvé ici un homme comme une
nouvelle fois tout de ce nous est une
douce 30 que ce monsieur jourde avec les
visions de noblesse et de galanterie
qu'il est allé se mettront en fait et
votre danse et ma musique
or est à souhaiter que tout le monde lui
ressemble non pas entièrement et je
voudrais pour lui qu'il se connaît mieux
qu'il ne fait autre chose que nous lui
donnons il est vrai qu'il les connaît
mal mais il les paye bien et sait de
quoi maintenant aux arts ont plus besoin
que de tout autre chose pour moi je
voulais vous je me repose un peu de
gloire les applaudissements me touche et
je tiens que dans tous les beaux-arts
c'est un supplice assez fâcheux que se
produira des sceaux que d'essuyer sur
des compositions la la barbarie d'un
stupide il y à plaisir ne m'en parlez
points à travailler pour des personnes
qui seraient capables de sentir les les
délicatesses d'un art qui s'achevèrent
1,12 accueil aux beautés d'un ouvrage et
par de chatoyantes approbation vous
régaler de votre travail
oui la récompense la plus agréable qu'on
puisse recevoir des choses que l'on fait
c'est de les voir connu les voir car et
c'est d'un applaudissement qui vous
honore il n'y a rien à mon avis qu'ils
nous payent mieux qu'au stade de toutes
nos fatigues et ce sont des douceur
exquise que des louanges éclairé jean
demeure d'accord et je les écoute comme
bout il n'y a rien assurément qui
chatouille davantage que les
applaudissements que vous dites mais cet
encens ne fait pas vivre dignement âge
tout pur
ne met pas un terme à son aise il faut
men et du solide et la meilleure façon
de louer ces de l'ouvrir avec les mains
c'est un homme à la vérité dont les
lumières son petit qui parlent à tort et
à travers de toutes choses et naples
audika contre sens mais son argent
redresse les jugements de son esprit il
a du discernement dans sa bourse encore
plus ses louanges son mobilier et ce
bourgeois ignorant nouveau mieux comme
vous voyez que le grand seigneur éclairé
qui nous a introduit ce que je trouve
que vous appuyez un peu trop sur
l'argent et l'intérêt est quelque chose
de si bas qu'il ne faut jamais qu'un
honnête homme montre pour lui de
l'attachement vous recevez fort bien sûr
tant l'argent que notre amour sommes
assurément mais je n'en fais pas tout
mon bonheur et je voudrais qu avec son
bien il y encore quelques bombes ou des
choses je le voudrais aussi c'est à quoi
nous travaillons tous d autant que vous
ment mais en tout cas il nous donne
moyen de nous faire connaître dans le
monde et une paiera pour les autres ce
que les autres n'auront pour lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
tous
oh
hop
et bien messieurs caisse me ferez vous
voir votre petit drôlerie comment quel
petit drôlerie les mousses la vôtre
prologue mondiale omm de chansons et de
danses au vous nous y voyez préparer pas
je vous ai fait un peut atteindre mais
c'est que je me fait oublier aujourd'hui
comme les gens de qualité et mon
tailleur m'a envoyé des bas de soie que
j'ai pensé ne mettra jamais nous ne
sommes ici que pour attendre votre
loisir
je vous prie sous 2 2 ne vous pointe en
aller qu'on mette à porter mon habit
afin que vous ne puissiez moi tout ce
qu'il vous plaira vous me verrez équipé
comme il faut depuis les pieds jusqu'à
la tête
nous n'en doutons point je me suis fait
faire c'est un bienne si on est fort
belle compte ailleurs m'a dit que les
gens de qualité comme cela le mat
cela vous sied à merveille oh la la
qu'est mais de là qu'est ce que voulez
vous monsieur n'à rien c'est pour voir
si vous m'entendez bien que dites vous
de mes livres et elles sont magnifiques
voici encore un petit déshabillé pour
faire le matin mes exercices sont
illégales en laqué monsieur l'autre là
qu'est monsieur donner ma robe me
trouvez vous bien comme cela fort bien
on ne peut pas mieux
voyons un peu votre affaire je voudrais
bien auparavant vous faire entendre un
air qu'il vient de composer pour la
sérénade
vous m'avez demandé c'est un de mes
écoliers qui pour ces sortes de choses
un talent admirable oui mais il ne
fallait pas faire faire cela par un
écolier vous n'étiez pas trop bon vous
même pour cette besogne là il ne faut
pas monsieur que le nom des colliers
vous abusez sortent des colliers en
sabre août tant que les plus grands
maîtres et l'air est aussi beau qu'il
sent puisse faire écouter seulement
venez moins marrant pour mieux entendre
attendez je crois que je serai mieux
sans robe longue randonnée là moi cela
ira mieux nantis les jours mon bonus
actionnaires
[Musique]
ont soumis si vous traîtres si lloris à
qui vous lance finances
que voulez vous faire
si vous traitez sarah cyril bagnost du
sac et russel il n'a que pour une et
vous faire
[Musique]
cette chanson me semble un peu lugubre l
andorre
je voudrais que vous la puce qui est un
peu ragaillardir par-ci par-là feu ce
que l'air soit à cocody aux paroles on
m'en a rien tout à fait joli il ya
quelques temps
attendez là comment est ce qu'il dit
dans ma foi je ne sais il y à du mouton
dedans oui à la vie la ligne et dana je
croyais janot trop aussi tout ce qu
bègles joaillier jeanneteau plutôt ce
cas vous
hélas hélas à nice en fois mille fois
plus creux vers lens allez cent fois
mille fois plus brûler comme elodie et
filtrage ni le plus haut niveau et vous
chantez bien c'est sans avoir appris la
musique devriez l'apprendre monsieur
comme vous faites la danse ce sont deux
arts qui ont une étroite liaison
ensemble et qu'il ouvre l'esprit d'un
homme aux belles choses mais ce que les
gens de qualité a peint aussi la musique
oui monsieur apprendre et non mais je ne
sais quel temps je pourrai prendre car
outre le maître d'armes qui me montre je
vais arrêter encore un maître de
philosophie qui doit commencer ce matin
la philosophie est quelque chose mais la
musique monsieur la musique et la danse
la musique et la danse c'est là tout ce
qu'il faut il n'y a rien qui soit si
utile dans un état que la musique a rien
qui sera aussi nécessaire aux hommes que
la danse soit la musique
un état ne peut subsister sans la danse
un homme ne saurez rien fait tous les
désordres toutes les guerres qu'on voit
dans le monde n'arrive que pour
l'apprendre pas la musique tous les
malheurs des hommes tous les revers
funeste dont les histoires sont remplies
les bévues des politiques les
manquements des grands capitaines tout
cela n'est venu que faute de savoir
danser au monstre la guerre ne
vient-elle pas d'un manque d'union entre
les hommes les vrais ici tous les hommes
apprenez la musique
ne serait ce pas le moyen de s'accorder
ensemble et de voir dans le monde
l'appel universel vous avez raison
lorsqu'un homme a commis un manquement
dans sa conduite soit aux affaires de sa
famille ou au gouvernement d'un état
tout haut commandement d'une armée ne
dit on pas toujours intel a fait un
mauvais pas dans une telle affaire
oui on dit cela et faire un mauvais pas
cela peut-il procédé d'autre chose que
de ne savoir pas danser sur un vrai vous
avez raison tous deux c'est pour vous
faire voir l'excellent c'est l'utilité
de la danse et de la musique
je compense la sete voulez-vous faire
nos deux affaires oui je voulais déjà
dit c'est un petit c'est que j'ai fait
autrefois des diverses passions que peut
exprimer la musique fort bien allons
avancer
il faut vous figurez qu'ils sont
habillés en verger pourquoi toujours des
berges et on ne voit que je là partout
lorsqu'on a des personnes à faire parler
en musique il faut bien que pour la
vraisemblance moncton dans la bergerie
le champ a été de tout temps affecté aux
bergers et les guerres vraisemblable en
dialogue que des princes a coûté bourg
soit chantent leur passion passe passe
voyons
[Musique]
m
santé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toujours magique
oui
[Musique]
non
si vous détendre et salades
il faut plus d'un
moby
de quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
non
et
sow
[Musique]
oh
et
ap
[Musique]
est ce tout oui je trouve cela bien
troussé ya là dedans
de petits dicton assez joli voici
comment on va faire un petit essai des
plus beaux mouvements à des plus belles
attitudes dont une danse puisse être
variés sens encore des bergers c'est ce
qu'il vous plaira alors messieurs
[Musique]
non
ah ben non ça va pas
[Musique]
mon
oh
[Musique]
m
e
[Musique]
voilà qui n'est point sont ils ces gens
là se trémousse bien lorsque la danse
sera mêlé avec la musique cela fera plus
d'effet encore et vous verrez quelque
chose de galan dans le petit balai que
nous avons ajusté pour vous c'est
pourtant tôt - il a personne pour qui
j'ai fait faire tout cela me dois faire
l'honneur de venir dîner c'est en tout
est prêt or est monsieur ce n'est pas
assez il faut qu'une personne comme vous
qui est magnifique et qui avait de la
fina sion pour les belles choses est un
concert de musique chez soi tous les
mercredis où tous les jeudis est ce que
les gens de qualité en nourrit mieux on
aurait donc cela sera-t-il beau sans
doute il vous faudra trois voire un
dessus notre contrée une basse qui
seront accompagnés d'une base de viol
d'un théorbe et d'un clavecin pour les
bases continue avec deux dessus de
violon pour les ritournelles il faudra
mettre aussi une trompette marine la
trompette marine est un instrument qui
me plaît et qui est harmonie laissez
nous gouverner les chevaux - n'oubliez
pas tantôt de m'envoyer des musiciens
pour chanter rata vous aurez tout ce
qu'il vous faut mais surtout que le
ballet soit pour vous en serez content
et entre autres choses de certains menus
est que vous y verrez à les menuets sont
made ans et je veux que vous me les
voiliers danser à lormont
là là là à vous monsieur et la la la la
la la la la la la
en 15 ans en
la la la la chanteuse droit un bon cru
[Musique]
- ce sont les la fois la plus mal à la
mettre la flèche
la pl vos bras sont espérés
[Musique]
la la la la la journée la moins utiles
en donnant la la la
on fait un bond
[Musique]
voilà qui est le mieux du monde à propos
apprenez loi comme il faut faire une
révérence pour saluer une marquise j'en
aurai besoin sans auto une révérence
pour saluer avec marc hé oui une
marquise qui s'appelle de rimmel donnez
moi la main non vous n'avez qu'à faire
je leur tiendrai bien si vous voulez la
salue avec beaucoup de respect il faut
faire une révérence en arrière puis
marcher vers celle avec trois références
en avant et à la dernière ou baisser
jusqu'à ces jours fait un peu
bon monsieur voilà votre maître d'armes
qui est là je veux que vous me voyez
frère alors mais c'est la résidence
retraite en droit peut pencher sur la
cuisse gauche au centre pointant et
gâter vos pieds cela même ligne votre
poignet à l'opposé des vôtres et hanches
lapointe qui est de votre épée vis à vis
de votre épouse et moi pas du tout
apprécié tendu la main gauche à la
hauteur des leurres l'épaule gauche +
cats et la tête droite et regard assuré
avancer
l'éco-ferme tous ces mois les plaies de
cas est assurée de mer oui des remettez
vous aurez doublé à 2,1 sont derrière
monsieur quand vous partez la boîte
monsieur pour que l'épée parties la
première est que les corps soient bien
effacer et 2 alors tous ces mois l'épée
de thiès gasmi des avancées mais qu'on
fait avancer partie de la haie de
remettez-vous redoublé ambitieux en
garde
vous fait des merveilles je voulais déjà
dit tous les secrets des armes les
consiste comme toujours atone et y aller
pour recevoir et comme je vous dis pas
le toujours par raison démonstrative il
est impossible que boisselier si vous
savez détourné l'épée de votre ennemi de
la ligne de votre corps ce qui ne dépend
seulement que d'un petit mouvement des
poignets wade dans ou en dehors de cette
façon dont un homme sans avoir du coeur
est sûre de tuer son homme est de notre
point de vue sans doute est l'invité
vous pas la démonstration
oui et c'est en quoi l'ombre desquels
considérations nous sautons nous devons
être dans un état et combien la science
des armes
l'impôt est hautement sur toutes les
autres c'est inutile est telle qu'ils la
dacie nouveau monsieur le tireur d'armes
nous paraît de la danse qu avec respect
apprenez je vous prie à mieux traiter
l'excellence de la musique êtes
déplaisante des gens de vous la comparez
mot science et art agnel william un peu
l'homme d'importance voilà un plaisante
animal avec son plastron petit mais
train d'assiéger me ferait danser comme
il faut et vous mon petit musicien j'ai
vous faisait chanter dit l'appel bayer
monsieur le batteur de faire je vous
apprendrai votre métier et vous fout de
l'allée querellés lui qui entend la tire
c'est la carte et qui s'est tué un homme
par maison démonstrative ne manque de
saison démonstrative et sa tierces et sa
carte ou nobody comment betty
impertinent est mon maître d'armes grand
cheval de chaos est mon maître à danser
si gêné chuté sur vous doucement
si je mets sur vous la main de bon et
vous écrirez d'un m je vous recevrai
d'une manière je vous prie que c'est moi
un peu d'apport par les rompus avec les
boues seront là monsieur le philosophe
vous arrivez tout à propos avec votre
philosophie connais un peu mettre la
paix entre ces personnes si qu'est ce
donc il y à t'il messieurs se sont mis
en colère pour la préférence de leur
profession jusqu'à se dire des injures
et vouloir en venir aux mains
et quoi mais je vote il s'emportait de
la sorte il n'avez vous point lui le
docte traité que ce n'est qu'a composé
de la colère y à t'il rien le plus bas
et le plus haut
2 que cette passion qui fait d'un homme
une bête féroce et la raison ne doit
elle pas être maîtresse de tous nos
mouvements
comment monsieur il vient nous dire des
injures à tous deux en méprisant la
danse que j'exerce et la musique dont il
fait profession un homme sage est au
dessus de toutes les injures quant à lui
peut dire et la grande réponse qu'on
doit faire aux outrages
c'est la modération et la passion tout
le monde a ajouté vouloir comparer leur
profession à billets faut-il que cela
vous émeuvent
ce n'est pas de veine gloire et de
condition que les hommes doivent
disputer entre eux et ce qui nous
distingue parfaitement les uns des
autres c'est la sagesse il a vécu je lui
soutient que la danse est une science à
laquelle on peut faire à ses donneurs et
moi que la musique en est une que tous
les sites ont rêvé réel moi je soutiens
tous deux classes science désarmer la
plus belle est nécessaire tu es toutes
les charges et que sera dans la
philosophie
je vous trouve tous trois viennent
impertinent d'oser me parler avec cette
arrogance et de données impudemment le
nom de sciences à des choses que l'on ne
doit pas même honoré d'une honda et
qu'ils ne peuvent être compris ce que
sous le nom de métier misérable de
gladiateurs de senteurs et de baladins
et puis le sentier chien à l'épée litres
de pédant allez mr fièvre et comment
marot que vous êtes monsieur le
philosophe informe qu'au 14 mai
au pathé pourtant qu'il vous plaira vous
savez ça fait séparés j'aurais bien vous
demain les foules et parmi eux quelques
coups monsieur je suis fâché des coûts
qu'ils vous ont donné l'année rien un
philosophe c'est comme il faut recevoir
les choses et je vais composer contre
une satire du style de juvénal qui les
déchire à la belle face à l'essence que
vous
tout ce que je pourrai car j'ai toutes
les envies du monde d'être savant et
j'enrage que mon père et ma mère ne met
pas fait bien étudié dans toutes les
sciences
quand j'étais jeune coisy mort teasing
vous entendez ce live vous savez la taxe
oui mais fait comme si je ne le savais
pas expliquez moi ce que cela veut dire
cela veut dire que sans la science lamy
est presque une image de la mort cela
tend la raison n'avez vous point
quelques principes quelques commencement
des sciences
oui je sais lire et écrire faro vous
plait-il que nous commencions voulez
vous que je vous apprennent à logique
qu'est ce que c'est que cette logique
c'est celle qui nous enseignent les
trois opérations de l'esprit qui son
hôtel ces trois opérations de l'esprit
la première la seconde et la troisième
première qui est de bien concevoir par
le moyen des universaux la seconde bien
juger par le moyen des catégories et la
troisième de bien tirer une conséquence
par le moyen des figures barbara c'est
là
darif et au bahreïn voilà des mots qui
sont trop rébarbatif
cette logique là ne me revient point à
prônes autre chose puisque le plus joli
voulez vous apprendre là
morale la morale oui qu'est ce qu'elle
dit cette morale elle traite de la
féliciter en scène et aux hommes à
modérer leur passion non laissons cela
je suis pile de comme tous les diables
et il n'ya morale qui tienne
je me veux mettre en colère tout mon
saoul quand il m'en prends ta vie
voulez-vous que je vous appelle la
physique qu'est ce qu'elle chante cette
physique physique et celle qui nous
enseignent les principes des choses
naturelles et les propriétés du corps
qui discourent de la nature des éléments
des métaux des minéraux des pierres des
plantes et des animaux et nous enseigne
cause de tous les météores l'arc-en-ciel
leaf volant lee commettent des éclairs
le tonnerre la foudre la pluie la neige
ou la grêle au livre en élite tourbillon
ya trop de tintamarre l'un d'eux d'ordre
de brouillamini que voulez vous donc que
je vous après apprenez - orthographe et
volontiers d'après vous me prendrez la
mana donc savoir quand il ya de la lune
et quand il y en a point soit pour bien
suivre votre pensée est prêté cette
matière en philosophe il faut commencer
selon l'ordre des choses par une exacte
connaissance de la nature des lettres et
de la différentes manières de les
prononcer tout est là dessus c'est à
vous dire que les lettres sont divisés
en voyait ainsi dit voyelles parce
qu'elle exprime la haine et en
consommation appelées consonnes parce
qu'elle sonne avec les fruits
ils ne font que marquer les diverses
articulations d'un mois
il y a cinq voyelles ou voix à eux y eut
j'entends tout cela la voie à se forme
en ouvrant fort la bouche à voir se
former en rapprochant la mâchoire d'en
bas de celle d'en haut a eu à 1
en cochant des bois et la voyait en
rapprochant encore davantage les
mâchoires l'une de l'autre et écartant
les deux coins de la bouche vers les
oreilles à eux y a eu et et y y
cela est vrai vive la science la boîte
ferme en rouvrant les mâchoires il
rapprochant les lèvres parler de coin le
haut et le bas ou euros
il n'y a rien de plus juste à eux aux
éau cela est admirable et au i o
l'ouverture de la bouche c'est justement
comme un petit rond qui représente un os
os aux eaux
vous avez raison ou à la belle chose que
de savoir quelque chose la voix il se
forme en rapprochant les dents sans les
joindre entièrement et allongeant les
lèvres rose en dehors des approchante
aussi l'une de l'autre sens les joindre
tout à fait pu eux il n'y a rien de plus
véritable ode aux lèvres salle oms comme
si vous faisiez la moue d'où vient que
si vous la voulez faire à quelqu'un et
vous moquer de lui vous ne sauriez lui
dire que cela est vrai que neige étudié
plus tôt pour savoir tous demain nous
verrons les autres lettres qui sont
l'air consomme
est ce qu'il y a des choses aussi
curieuse cassel c'est sans doute la
console t par exemple se prononce en
donnant du bout de la langue
au dessus des dents au da da da aux
émirats les belges leif en appuyant les
dents sur la lèvre de dessous fa fa fa
c'est la vérité à mon père et ma mère
que je vous veux de mal heller emportant
le bout de la langue jusqu'au du palais
de sorte qu'ils aient tant frôlé par
l'est
r qui sort avec force elle lui cède et
revient toujours au même endroit faisant
une manière de tremblements cela est
vrai au labit l'homme que vous étés que
j'ai perdu de temps ah je vous
expliquerai à fond toutes ces curiosités
je vous en prie on reste il faut que je
vous fasse une confidence je suis
amoureux d'une personne de grande
qualité et je souhaiterais que vous mais
dassier à lui écrire quelque chose dans
un petit billet je voudrais laisser
tomber à ses pieds fort bien
cela sera galant oui sans doute sont ce
des verts que voulez-vous les écrire non
point vert vous ne voulez que de la
prose
non je ne veux ni pro univers il faut
bien que ce soit l'un ou l'autre
pourquoi par la raison monsieur qu'il
n'ya pour s'exprimer que la prose ou les
verts il y a que la prose ou les verts
mais monsieur tout ce qui n'est point un
projet vert et tout ce qui n'est point
vers et prose et comme l'on parle
qu'est-ce que sait-on que cela de la
prose
pourquoi quand je dis nicolas porter moi
mes pantoufles et me donner mon bonnet
de nuit c'est c'est de la provoc oui
monsieur tard ma foi il n'y a plus de 40
ans que je dis de la peau sans que j'en
suis rien et je vous suis le plus
obligés du monde de m'avoir appris cela
je voudrais donc lui mettre dans un
billet belle marquise vos beaux yeux me
font mourir d'amour mais je voudrais que
cela fût mis d'une manière galante
ce fut tourné gentiment m que les feux
le seuil eux réduisent leur procurant
cendres que vous souffrez 8 et jour pour
elle et violent à ce non non non je ne
veux pas tout cela je ne veux que ce que
je vous ai dit belle marquise vos pauses
yeux me font mourir d'amour faut bien
d'étendre un peu le souk où vous dit je
ne veux que ces seules paroles là dans
le billet mais tourné à la mode ghana
rangés comme il faut je vous prie de me
dire un peu
revoir les diverses manière dont on les
peu m on les peut mettre premièrement
comme vous avez dit belle marquise vos
beaux yeux me font mourir d'amour ou
bien d'amour mourir me font belle
marquise vos beaux yeux ou bien vos yeux
beau d'amour me font belle marquise
mourir ou bien mourir vos beaux yeux
belle marquise d'amour me font ou bien
me font vos yeux vaut mourir belle
marquise d'amour mais de toutes ces
façons là là quelle est la meilleure
celle que vous avez dit bell maryse vos
beaux yeux me font mourir d'amour
cependant je n'ai point étudié j'ai fait
cela tout du premier coup
je vous remercie de tout mon coeur et
vous prie de venir demain de bonheur
je n'y manquerai pas
comment mon avis n'est pas encore arrivé
non monsieur ce maudit d'ailleurs me
fait bien attendre pour un jour où j'ai
trop d'affaires j'enrage que la fièvre
cartel puisse dire est bien fort le bon
duc traille heures au garde le tailleur
la peste étouffe le trailer
si je le connais maintenant ce tailleur
détestable ces chiens de taille or là ce
traître de tailleur vous voilà je
m'allie mettre en colère contre vous je
n'ai pas retenir plus tôt et j'ai mis
vingt garçons après votre avis vous
m'avez envoyé des bas de soie si les
droits que j'ai eu toutes les peines du
monde à les mettre et il ya déjà deux
mâles de rompre il ne s'élargit rond que
trop oui si je romps toujours des
mailles
vous m'avez aussi fait faire des
souliers qui me blesse furieusement
point du tout me sur comment coin du
tout non il ne voulait ce point je vous
dis qu'il me blesse mois vous vous
imaginez ce n'est pas je me l'imaginais
parce que je le sens vous voyez la belle
raison
tenez voilà le plus bel habit de la cour
et le mieux assorti
c'est un shader que d'avoir inventé un
avis sérieux qui ne fut pas noir je le
donne en sic ou au tailleur n'est plus
éclairée
qu'est ce que c'est que ce si vous avez
mis les fleurs en en bas et paddy
voulez-vous liées au non est-ce qu'il
faut dire cela oui vraiment toutes les
personnes de qualité les portes de la
sorte les personnes de qualité porte les
fleurs on a en bas oui monsieur euro
voilà qui est donc bien si vous voulez
je le mettrais au non non non vous
n'avez qu'à dire non vous dis-je
vous avez bien fait voyez vous que
l'habit mec bien rebelles demandent je
défie à un peintre avec son pinceau de
vous faire rien de plus juste j'ai chez
moi un garçon qui pour monter leur un
grave et le plus grand génie du monde et
un autre qui pourra sembler amour points
et le héros de notre temps
la perruque et les plumes sont elles
comme il faut tout est bien antérieur
voilà demont et off du dernier habite
vous m'avez fait je la reconnais bien
oui c'est que les toffes me sembla si
belle que j'en ai voulu lever à la vie
pour moi oui mais il ne fallait pas le
lever avec le mien voulez vous mettre
votre habit oui donnez le moi attendait
cela ne va pas comme cela
j'ai amené des gens pour vous habiller
en cadence et ces sortes dhabi se met
avec cérémonie à la rentrée nous autres
mettez s'établit à monsieur de la
manière que vous faites aux personnes de
qualité
[Musique]
on
mon gentilhomme me donnez s'il vous
plaît aux garçons quelque chose pour
voir comment appelez-vous mon
gentilhomme voilà ce que c'est le seul
maître en personne de qualité
allez-vous-en demeurer toujours habillé
en bourgeois on ne vous dira point mon
gentil garçon brun tenez voilà pour mon
gentilhomme monseigneur nous vous sommes
bien obligés mon single bourreau bon
seigneur attendait mon ami mon seigneur
mérite quelque chose et ce n'est pas une
petite parole que monseigneur tenez
voilà ce que monseigneur vous donne mon
seigneur nous allons boire tous à la
santé de votre grande votre grandeur
rojo attendait ne vous en allez pas à
moi votre grandeur ma foi s'il va
jusqu'à l'altesse il aura toute la
bourse
sony voilà pour ma grandeur
monseigneur nous la remercions très
humblement de ces libéralités
il a bien fait je lui allaient tout
donner suivez moi que je viens peut
montrer mon avis par la ville
ayez soin tous deux de marche
immédiatement sur mes pas afin qu'on
voit bien que vous êtes à moi oui
monsieur
appelez-moi nicole que je lui donne
quelques en france je croyais
notons aussi d'autres copains
je ne croyais aux gens le ton plutôt
choquant moutons et là que tu arrives
[Musique]
vous voilà voulons qu'elle serait bon et
cela te moques de moi n'est ni monsieur
on serait bien passé de voirie sur le
nez ces tueries davantage je ne
s'arrêtera pas s'en tenir
mais voyez quelle insolence ou bien s'il
serait encore le moins du monde je te
jure que goethe appliquerait sur la joue
le plus grand soufflet qui se soit
jamais donné et bien monsieur moitié ces
sonneries ray plus rangée bien garé il
faut que pourtant tout ne nous dit que
tu les toits comme il faut et on discute
une étoile a pâli ces messieurs pas
tellement les séries du genre je te
prends jamais vu cependant comme celle
là qui me vient rire insolemment sonné
au lieu de recevoir mes cordes que
voulez-vous que tu poses coquines à
préparer ma maison pour l'accompagner
qui doit venir faux je n'ai plus envie
de rire toutes vos compagnies font tant
de désordres ayant que ce mot est assez
pour mettre nos résumés doivent pas
pourquoi fermer ma porte à tout le monde
de brillants au moins la ferme et à
certaines gens
voici nouvelliste toi qu'est-ce que ce
dont mon mari que cet équipage la moquée
bout du monde depuis notre père
harnachés de la sorte
et là me voir dit qu'on sera il parle de
vous il n'y a que des shows et des shots
ma femme qui se rallieront deux mois
vraiment on n'a pas attendu jusqu'à la
70e et il ya longtemps de façon de faire
de tarir à tout le monde qui est donc
tout ce monde là s'il vous plaît tout ce
montage est un monde qui a raison et qui
est plus sage que vous pour moi je suis
scandalisée de la vie que vous menez
sais c'est que notre maison
on dirait qu'ils essaient en carême
prenant tous les jours et elle matin de
peur du manque et on y entend des 20-40
de violon de chanteurs dont tout le
voisinage se trouve accommoder madame
par le bien je ne serai plus va mon
ménage propre avec cet attirail de gens
qui ont fait venir chez vous sont des
pieds qui vont chercher de la boue dans
tous les quartiers de la ville pour la
porter ici et là pauvre françoise est
presque sur les dents à frotter les
planches et que vos pions m viennent
crottés régulièrement tous les jours
ouais notre cerveau une école vous avez
le cac est bien affilée pour une
paysanne nique à la raison et son sens
est meilleur que le vôtre voudrais bien
savoir ce que vous pensez faire de
maître à danser à l'âge que vous avez
d'un grand maître tireur d'armes qui
vient avec ses battements de pieds
ébranlé toute la maison nous déraciner
tous les cas rien de neuf salles chez
nous me servante et ma femme parce que
vous voulez apprendre à danser pour
quand vous n'aurez plus de jambes
vous avez envie de tuer quelqu'un taisez
vous dire vous êtes des ignorante l'une
et l'autre et vous ne savez pas les
prérogatives de tout cela vous devriez
plutôt songer à marier votre fille qui
est en âge d'être pourvus je songerais à
marier ma fille quand il se présentera
un parti pour elle mais je veux
songerait aussi à apprendre les belles
choses j'ai encore ouï dire madame qu'il
a pris aujourd'hui pour renfort de
partage un même nom de philosophie fort
bien
je veux avoir de l'esprit et savoir
raisonnée des choses parmi les honnêtes
gens nus revo pollen ce jour au collège
nous faire damner le fouet à votre âge
pourquoi non plus un duo l'avoir tout à
l'heure le fouet devant tout le monde
essabar ce qu'on apprend au collège oui
ma foi ça vous rendre
un jean bien mieux fait sans doute tous
les efforts nécessaires pour conduire
votre maison assurément vous parlez
toutes deux comme des bêtes et j'ai
honte de votre ignorance
par exemple savez vous ce que c'est que
vous dites c'est oui je sais que ce que
je dis est fort bien dit et que vous
devriez songer à vivre d'autres sortes
je ne parle pas de cela je vous demande
ce que c'est que les paroles que vous
dites ici ce sont des paroles bien sensé
et votre conduite n'est guère
je ne parle pas de cela vous dis je vous
demande ce que je parle avec vous ce que
je vous dis à cette heure qu'est ce que
c'est tes chansons et non ce n'est pas
cela
ce que nous disons tous deux le langage
que nous parlons à 7h et bien mais
comment est-ce que cela s'appelle ça
s'appelle comment veut appeler ses de la
prose ignorante
oui de la pause tout ce qui est prôné
points vers tout ce qui n'est pas un
verre n'est point prose voilà ce que
c'est d'étudier et toi si tu viens
comment il faut faire pour dire m
comment oui qu'est ce que tu fais quand
tu dis à un but dit un peu pour voir et
bien eu qu'est ce que tu fais je dis oui
mais quand tu dis vu qu est ce que tu
fais je fais ce que l'on me dit oh les
tranches chose que d'avoir à faire à des
bêtes tu allonge les lèvres en dehors et
approches la mâchoire d'en haut de celle
d'en bas
une voiture je fais l'amour une wii
voyage est admirable c'est bien autre
chose si vous avez vu ou aidé à faire ce
que c'est donc tout ce galimatias l'art
de bosses que tous la guerre j'enrage
quand je vois des femmes dignes euros
vous devriez envoyé promener tous ces
gens là avec leur pari bol surtout ce
grotesque aux cris de m darne qui rempli
de poudre tout en ménage ouais ce maître
d'un bouquin forte que je te veux faire
voir ton impertinent scooter tiens
rivaux démonstrative la ligne du corps
quand on pousse sans carte
on n'a qu'à faire peur et quand on
pousse en clair ça on n'a qu'à faire
cela
voilà le moyen de n'être jamais fait et
cela n'est-il pas bon d'être assuré de
son fait
quand on se bat contre quelqu'un pousse
point un peu pour voir et bien croire
que vos mouvements
diouf soit la coquille me dit de pousser
oui mais tu me poussant retire avant
coup de pouce et en cartes et tu n'as
pas la patience que je pars tous ces
fous mon mari allait toutes vos
fantaisies et cela vous est venu depuis
que vous vous mêlez de rente et la
noblesse
lorsque je rentre la noblesse jeu fait
paraître mon jugement et soleil plutôt
que d'orienter votre bourgeoisie sommes
vraiment il y à fort à gagner à
fréquenter vos nobles et vous avez bien
appéré avec ce pot monsieur le comte
donc vous êtes en buggy nevers songer à
ce que vous dites savez-vous bien ma
femme que vous ne savez pas de qui vous
parlez quand vous parlez de lui c'est
une personne d'importance plus qu'à vous
de tence un seigneur que l'on considère
à la cour et qui par le roi tout comme
je vous parle pas une chose qui met tout
à fait honorable que l'on va venir chez
moi c'est souvent une personne de cette
qualité qui m'appelle son cher ami me
traite comme si j'étais son égard il a
pour moi d'hébron t on ne devinerais
jamais et devant tout le monde
il me fait des caresses dont je suis
moi-même confus oui il a des bontés pour
vous et vous fait des caresses mais vous
en prendre notre argent est bien nommé
ce poids de l'honneur de prêter de
l'argent à un lob de cette condition là
et puis je faire moins pour un seigneur
qui m'appelle sont chers amis et se
saigne air que fait-il pour vous des
choses dont on serait étonné si on les
savait et quoi penses-tu je ne peux pas
m'expliquer il suffit que si je lui ai
prêté de l'argent
il me le rendra bien avant qu'il soit
peu oui
attendez vous à cela
assurément le bloc il pas dit oui il ne
manquera pas d'éveiller il m'a juré sa
foi de gentilles en ce sens ouais vous
êtes bien l'obstiné ma femme je vous dis
qu'il me tiendra parole
j'en suis sûr et moi je suis sûr que non
en tout cas reste il vous fait le soudan
journée mettez-vous de voici
il ya peut-être encore vous faire
quelques emprunts et il me sens plus
chez tine et quand je le vois taisez
vous vous dis-je
mon cher monsieur comment apporter fort
bien monsieur pouvoir amener petit
service et 20 jours voilà comment se
porte-t-elle même jean d'assé par pr
neil peu comme monsieur jourdain
nous voilà le plus propre du monde voyez
vous avez tout à fait bonheur avec cet
habit et nous n'avons point de jeunes
gens à la cour qu'ils soient mieux
faites vous le drapeau rouge c'est
dément je joue mais vous au horn
cela est tout à fait galant lui aussi sa
part derrière départ de vos mâchoires ce
chantage avait une impatience étrange de
vouloir vous êtes l'homme montrent que
j'estime le plus et je parlais de vous
encore ce matin dans le champ du roy me
fait beaucoup d'honneur monsieur chambre
des rois allons mettre des cieux je sais
le respect que je vous dois mon dieu
mais tais toi tu serais venu entre nous
je vous prie monsieur
mettez vous dis-je monsieur jourdain
vous êtes mon ami monsieur je suis votre
service je me couvrait pas si vous ne
vous couvrez j'ai mieux géré raji ville
qu'importe je suis votre débiteur comme
vous le savez oui mais ces rencontres on
vous m'avez généreusement prêté de
l'argent à plusieurs occasions et vous
m'avez obligé de la meilleure grâce du
monde assuré me sur vous vous moquez
mais je sais rendre ce qu'on prête à
reconnaître les plaisirs comme fer je
n'en doute point
je veux sortir d'affaires avec vous et
je viens ici pour faire nos comptes
ensemble eh bien vous voyez votre
impertinence
je suis homme qui m a quitté le plus tôt
que je fais je vous le disais bien
voyons un peu ce que je vous dois
voilà avec vos soupçons ridicule vous
souvenez vous bien de tout l'argent vous
avez prêté
je crois que oui j'en ai fait un petit
mémoire le voici donné à vous une fois
200 laurie se lève notre foire 6 20 oui
une fois son 40e
vous avez raison ces trois articles font
460 louis qui valent 5068 le côté fort
bon 5068 1832 livre à votre place y est
justement 2007 180 livres votre
intérieur une vraie 4379 livre du sceau
lui donniez à votre marche fort bien 12
selon lui donniez le comté geste et 1748
livres 7 sol quatre thoniers à votre
celi tous très véritable qu'est ce que
cela fait somme totale 15 1800 livres
nous sommes totales juste quinze mille
huit cent vivent m'étais encore 200
pistoles que vous m'avez donné ça va
justement 18 mille francs que je vous
paierai au premier jeu et bien je
l'avais je crois bien deviné cela vaut
un camarade de me donner ce que je vous
dis et non
cet homme là faites vous une vache à
lait c est trop non si ça vous encourage
à les rechercher
non monsieur ne sera pas content qu'il
vous erwin et s'il vous plaît vous
n'avez que veut dire si ça vous
embarrassent point monsieur c'est un
vrai on joue le tg boudon qui vous ce
sera jusqu'au dernier sou terry vous
j'ai forcé genre tu m'en faut être avec
je vois pas mais comme vous êtes mon
meilleur ami
j'ai cru que je vous souhaite heures
c'est jean mauriac
comme c'est trop d'honneur monsieur que
vous me faites je vais guérir votre
affaire vous avez encore lui donner cela
que faire voulez vous que je refuse un
homme de cette condition là qui a parlé
de moi ce matin dans la chambre du roi
mais allez vous êtes une vraie équipe
vous semblez tout mélancolie
qu'avez vous madame jourdain et la tête
plus grosse quel point je n'ai pas enflé
mademoiselle votre fille souhaitait que
je ne la vois point mademoiselle ma
fille est bien où il est comment se
porte peuvent elles se portent sur ses
deux jambes ne voulez vous pas un séjour
venir voir avec elle le ballet la
comédie qui l'ont fait chez le roi oui
vraiment nous avons forte envie de rire
forte envie de rien nous avons je pense
dans la journée que vous avez eu bien
des avantages
lebel et d'agréable humeur comme vous
étiez monsieur est ce que madame chantal
décrépite et à 4 les bourreaux étaient
déjà en ma foi me lapp journal je vous
demande pardon je ne songeais pas de
vous êtes jeune et je rêve le plus
souvent je vous prie d'excuser mon
impertinence 200 louis bien content et
je vous assure monsieur jourdain que je
suis tout sauf que je brûle de vous
rendre un service à la cour
je vous suis trop affligées si madame
jourdain de voir le divertissement royal
je lui ferai donner les meilleures
places de la salle un journal belge
humain notre belle marquise que je vous
ai demandé par mon billet viendra tantôt
ici pour le ballet d'europe et je les
fais pour sentir enfin beau cadeau que
voulez-vous d'élever tirons-nous un peu
plus loin pourquoi
il ya huit jours que je ne vous ai vu et
je ne vous ai pas demandé de nouvelle du
diamant que vous me dites entre les
mains pour le fr présente d'autre part
mais c'est que j'ai toutes les peines du
monde à vaincre sans scrupules et ce
n'est que d'aujourd'hui qu'elle s'est
résolu à accepter
comment l'at elle est tombée merveilleux
et je trouve fort où la beauté de ce
diamant fera pour vous sur son esprit en
effet admirable plutôt ciel quand il est
une fois le clip est petit et je lui
fais valoir comme une folle la richesse
ce présent et la grandeur de votre amour
ce sens monsieur despentes et qui
m'accable je suis dans une confusion la
plus grande du monde de voir une
personne de votre qualité s'abaisser
pour moi ce que vous êtes vous
moquez-vous s contre amiens s'arrête à
ces sortes de scrupules et ne feriez
vous pas pour moi la même chose si
l'occasion sang neuf ferait assurément
et de très grands que pour moi je ne
regarde rien quand il faut servir un ami
et lorsque vous ma fille de confidences
de l'ardeur que vous aviez prises pour
cette marquise agréable chez qui
j'allais commerce pour vite que d'abord
je veux offrir de moi-même à servian
faudra bourg il est vrai ce sont des
bontés qui le confondent ce qui te dira
point il se trouve bien ensemble vous
avez pris le bon pied pour toucher son
coeur les femmes aiment surtout les
dépenses qu'en fait pour elle et vous
fréquentez rue main vous bouter
continuelle ce superbe feu d'artifice
qu'elle trouva sur l'eau le diamant que
la russie de votre part est le cadeau
que vous lui préparer tous saluent par
le bienvenu en faveur de votre amour que
tous tes paroles que vous auriez pu lui
dire vous même
il n'y a pas de dépenses que jeune fils
ci par là je pouvais trouver une seule
main de son coeur une femme de qualité a
pour moi des charmes ravissant c'est un
honneur que j'achèterai prix de toute
chose un petit temps dire ensemble
tous membres et ils auraient ce sera
tantôt vous jouez à votre aise du
plaisir de sa vie et vos yeux en tout le
temps nous se disent faire pour être en
pleine liberté je fais en sorte que ma
femme ira dîner chez ma soeur où elle
passera toute l'après dîner vous avez
fait prudemment est il votre femme
aurait plus de sens de reims et j'ai
donné pour vous leur dire qu'il faut
qu'ils signé et à toutes les choses qui
sont nécessaires pour le ballet et il
est mon invention et pourvu que
l'exécution puisse répondre à l'idée
je suis sûr qu'il sera trouvé ouais
sortant s'il vous plaît la fois madame
la curiosité m'a coûté quelque chose
mais je crois qu'il ya quelques
anguilles sous roche
il parle de quelques affaires où ils ne
veulent pas que vous soyez cette preuve
aujourd'hui nicole que j'ai conçu des
soupçons de mon mari je suis là pu
tromper du monde où il y à quelques
amours en campagne et je travaille à
découvrir ce que c'est peut-être mais
songeons à ma fille tu c'est l'amour que
cliente a pour elle c'est un homme qui
me revient et je faisais des recherches
il lui donne et lucile si je puis en
vérité madame je suis la plus ravie du
monde de vous voir dans ses sentiments
car si le maître vous revient le valais
ne me revient pas moi et je souhaiterais
que notre mariage pu faire un nombre de
larves attendu parler de ma part et lui
dire que tout à l'heure il me viennent
trouver pour faire ensemble à mon mari
la demande demeure
j'y cours madame avec joie et je ne
pouvais recevoir une commission plus
agréable j'avais je pense bien riche
dirigeants abc tout à propos je suis non
pas fabrice de joie et je me retire toi
perfide et ne me vient point s'amuser
avec les trapèzes parole toi te dit il
va t'en dire de ce patron infidèle mais
presque l n'abusera de sa vie le
transept cléon vertigo un second la
papauté bien dis moi parce que c'est mon
gros covial petit scélérate
alors vite on tutoie de meyzieu vilaine
mls en repos je me prépare mes yeux te
dis et ne me parles de ta vie
mouche les a piqués tous deux à long de
cette belle histoire en forme est ma
maîtresse traiter en amont de la sorte
et une amende plus fidèle et le plus
passionné de tous les amants une chose
épouvantable que ce qu'on nous fait à
tous deux je veux voir pour une personne
toute l'ardeur et toute la tendresse
qu'on peut imaginer
je n'aime rien au monde qu'elle est
jeune et qu'elle dans l'esprit elle fait
tous mes soins tous mes désirs toute ma
joie
je ne parle que d'elle je ne pense qu'à
elle je ne fais des songes que d'elle je
ne respire que par l mon coeur vie tout
en elle et voilà deux ans d'amitié la
digne récompense je suis deux jours sans
l'avoir qui sont pour moi deux siècles
effroyable je la rencontre par hasard
mon coeur a séduit ce sens tout
transporter ma joie éclate sur mon
visage je vole avec ravissement
vairelles mois ces regards et passe
brusquement comme si de sa vie elle ne
m'avait vu jeudi les mêmes choses que
vous me souviens avoir d'égal covial à
cette perfidie de l'ingrate lucile et à
celle monsieur de l'ap hm tarder à
nicole après tant de sacrifices ardent
de soupirer de voeux que j'ai fait à ses
charmes prétendent assidus hommage de
soins et de services que je lui ai rendu
dans sa cuisine en de larmes que j'ai
versé à ses genoux temps de sault donc
j'ai tiré au pis pour l andorre que j'ai
fait paraître à la chérir plus que moi
même temps des chaleurs que j'ai
souffert ta tournée la brosse à sa place
et puis avec mépris elle ne tourne le
dos avec effronterie c'est une perfidie
digne des plus grands sentiments c'est
une trahison mérité mille souffler
établi ce point je te prie de me parler
jamais pour elle - monsieur budget manga
revient pas m'excuser l'action de cet
incident elle me dit j'ai pas peur
j'attends tout et discours pour la
défendre desserviront dernière qui songe
à cela je veux qu'on prenne conserver
mon ressentiment
on reprend sort de tout le commerce j'ai
consent
monsieur le comte qui va chez elle lui
donne peut-être dans la vue et son
esprit je le vois bien se laisser
bouillir à la qualité mais il me faut
pour mon honneur prévenir l éclat de son
inconstance
je veux faire autant de pâques elle aux
changements que je la vois courir et ne
lui laissait pas toute la gloire de me
quitter
c'est fort bien dit et j'entreprends mon
compte dans tous vos sentiments donne la
même en dépit et soutient la résolution
contre tous les restes d'amour qui me
pourrait parler pour elle dimanche je
t'en conjure tout le mal que tu pourras
fais-moi de sa personne une peinture qui
me la rendre méprisable et marc moi bien
paume en dégoûter tous les défauts que
tu peux voir en elle elle monsieur voilà
une belle mijaurée pas besoin bien bâti
pour vous donner tant d'amour je ne vois
rien que de très médiocre et votre
vincent personnes qui sont plus d'une de
vous premièrement elle a les yeux petits
cela et voilà les yeux petits mais les
appela le feu et les plus brillants et
les plus personne du monde le plus
touchant qu'on puisse voir
elle a la bouche grande nuit mais on y
voit des grosses qu'on ne voit point
tous autres bouche et cette bouche en la
voyant inspire des désirs est la plus
attrayante la plus amoureuse du monde
pour sa taille et n'est pas grande
non mais elle est aisé bien prise elle a
fait qu'une manche à lens dans son
parler dans ces axes il est vrai mais
c'est la grâce à tout cela
ses manières sont engageants prochaine
c4 charme assassiné dans les coeurs pour
de l'esprit lendemain à coquelles du
plus fin du plus délicat sa conversation
vers sa tion et charmante est toujours
sérieuse veux tu descends jument
épanouie de ses joies toujours ouvertes
il vaut plus rien de plus impertinent
que des femmes qui rit à tout propos
mais enfin les capricieuses autant que
personnellement oui elle est capricieuse
genre demeurent d'accord mais tout s'est
bien ouvert on souffre tous des belles
puisque cela va comme ça je vois bien
que vous avez envie d'aimer toujours moi
j'aimerais mieux mourir et je vais la
ire autant qu il a aimée le moyen si
vous la trouvez ci parfaite
c'est en quoi ma vengeance sera plus
éclatant
en quoi je veux faire mieux voire la
force de mon coeur est là à lire à la
quitter tous de belle toute pleine
d'attraits toutes aimables que je la
trouve la voit ici
moi j'en ai fait tout ce qu'on a vu
c'est peut-être une école que ce que je
t'ai dit je ne veux pas seulement lui
parler je veux vous imiter mais tu donc
aux vielles qu'elle s'aggrave face à cam
mauvaise humeur se tient est promu à
cléon du perdu la parole que viennent
les voilà qui est scélérat que cela et
judas janvier que la rencontre de tantôt
à troubler votre esprit à on voit ce
qu'on a fait notre accueil de ce matin
tu as fait de prendre ma chaise on a
deviné l'enclos sûrs c'est pas vrai que
les onze que c'est là le sujet de votre
dif ou hyper filles de l'est puisqu'il
faut parler et j'ai à vous dire que vous
ne triomphera pas comme vous pensé de
votre fidélité que je vous être le
premier à rompre avec vous et que vous
n'aurez pas l'inventaire je veux me
chasser
j'aurais de la peine sans doute à
vaincre l'amour que j'ai pour vous cela
me coûtera des chats gras je souffrirais
un temps mais j'en viendrais à bout je
me perds c'est plutôt le coeur que
d'avoir la faiblesse de retourner avoue
qu'elle si calmes et flavien des bruits
pour un rien je veux vous dire que les
autres le sujet qui m'a fait ce matin
est vite et votre amour non je ne
veuille à l'écouté je te veux apprendre
la cause qui nous a fait passer si vite
je ne veux rien entendre c'est que ce
matin nous apprend que je suis saoul et
aux noms comme - jenson pâques at elle
vraiment moi du tout à bout de patience
avare de paroles n'ont en effet plus de
commerces
il y avait ce que vous ne devez pas
m'écouter demeurer dans votre pensée et
fait ce qu'elle vous plaira
puisque tu fais comme cela pour le tout
comme tu voudras
sachant dont le sujet d'un si bel
accueil il me plaît plus que le dire
apprenons un peu cette histoire je ne
veux plus - te l'apprendre contre moi je
ne compte rien de bon non par charité
voilà fait je vous en prend laissez moi
je t'en conjure au tagueur lucie nicol
droite au nom de dieu
ce n'est pas par le voir wade tout est
classé ce médoune jeune frère yann moix
l'us navy ne me plaît pas
eh bien puisque vous vous souciez si peu
de me tirer de peine et de vous
justifier du traitement indigne que vous
avez fait à ma flamme
vous ne voyez ingrate pour la dernière
fois et je veux loi de vous mourir de
douleur et d'amour
et moi je vais suivre ses parts sociales
ou allez vous je vous ai dit ce salon
mourir j'allais mourir car moi je veux
que vous mourriez oui vous qui vous le
dit vouloir que ne vouloir pas
d'éclaircir les soupçons
est-ce la faute et si vous aviez voulu
m'écouter ne vous aurait pas dit que l'
aventure dont vous vous plaignez a été
causé ce matin par la présence d'une
vieille tante qui veut à toute force que
la seule approche de nomme déshonore une
fille et et qui perpétuellement nous sur
moine sur ce chapitre et nous figurent
tous les hommes comme titi a rappelé
qu'il faut fuir
voilà le secret de la faire mais tromper
vous point un missile mais malone tu
prêt à garder ou n'est rien de plus vrai
c'est la chose comme allez vous rendre
au nouveau hall us il qu'avec un mot de
votre bouche vous savez à plessé de
choses dans mon coeur et que facilement
s'y laisse persuader aux personnes qu'on
aime on était et mamadou éparses et
diantre d'animaux là je suis bien aise
de vous voir cléonte et vous voilà tout
à propos mon mari vient
prenez vite autant pour lui demandez lui
s'il en mariage madame que cette parole
mais douce et qu elle flatte me désire
pouvait recevoir un ordre plus charmant
une faveur plus précieuses
monsieur je n'ai voulu prendre personne
pour vous faire une demande que je
médite il ya longtemps
elle me touche assez pour m'en charge et
moi même et sans autre détour je vous
dirais que l'honneur d'être votre gendre
est une faveur glorieuse que je vous
prie de m'accorder avant que de vous
rendre réponse monsieur je vous prie de
me dire si vous êtes gentilhomme
mais la plupart des gens sur cette
question n'hésite pas beaucoup ont
tranché les mots aisément ce nom ne fait
aucun scrupule à prendre et il usage
aujourd'hui semble autoriser le vol pour
moi je voulais vous j'ai des sentiments
sur cette matière un peu plus délicat je
trouve que toute imposture est indigne
d'un étonnant est qu'il ya de la lâcheté
à déguiser ce que le ciel nous
actionnaires à se parer aux yeux du
monde va titre dérobé à ceux voulant
donner pour ce qu'on n'est pas
je suis né de parents sans doute qu'ils
ont tenu des charges honorable je me
suis acquis dans les armes l'honneur de
6 ans de service je me trouve assez des
biens pour tenir dans le monde à rend
assez passable mais avec tout cela je ne
veux pas me donner un nom ou d'autres on
ma place coire et pouvoir prétendre et
je vous dirais franchement que je ne
suis point gentilhomme où tu fais là
monsieur ma fille n'est pas pour vous
comment vous les toits un gentilhomme
vous n'aurez pas ma fille que voulez
vous dire avec votre gentilhomme est ce
que nous sommes nous autres de la côte
de saint louis
j'ai vu ma femme je vous vois venir
descendons nous tous deux que de bonnes
manches loisy voilà pas le coup de
langue et votre pea n'était-il pas
marchand ou si bien que le mien feist
soit de la femme elle n'y a jamais
manqué si votre père a été marchand tant
pis pour lui mais pour le mien ce sont
des mal avisée qui dit cela tout ce que
j'ai à vous dire moi c'est que je veux
avoir un gendre tranquille
il faut à votre fille un mari qui lui
soit propre et il vaut mieux pour elle
un honnête homme riche et bien c'est
qu'un gentilhomme vieux et mal bâti
cela est vrai nous avons le fils du
gentilhomme de notre village et plus
grand malheur n'est plus tout à fait des
années qu'ils veulent et vous
impertinente où vous pourrez toujours
dans la conversation
j'ai dû bien assez pour ma fille je n'ai
besoin que d'une heure et je vous
l'avais fait remarquer marquise wii
party et la dieu m'en garde
c'était une fausse couche est révolu
c'est une fin en soi où je ne
consentirait coin les alliances avait
plus grande foi consiste toujours à ses
inconvénients
je ne veux pas qu un gendre puis ça ma
fille reprocher ses parents et qu'elle
ait des enfants qui ont démarré leur
grand maman il fallait qu'elle nous
invitons l'équipage de grand dam et
qu'elle manque a par mégarde a salué
quelqu'un du quartier
on ne manquerait pas aussitôt de guerre
sans souci voyez-vous une réponse est
madame la marquise qui s'étend la
glorieuse et la pluie de monsieur
jourdain était trop peureux c'est
impossible de jouer à la madame avec mu
elle n'a pas toujours été aussi relevé
que la voilà et ses deux grands-pères
vendée durant auprès de la force
intéressante
ils ont amassé du bien à leurs enfants
qu'ils payent maintenant peut-être bien
cher en notre monde et l'on devient
guerre si riche à être honnêtes gens je
ne veux point c'est qu'à quai
je veux un homme en amont qui met
applications de ma fille et à qui je
puisse dire
mettez-vous l'art mon gendre et dîner
avec moi voilà bien les sentiments d'un
petit esprit demeurait toujours dans la
bassesse
je ne me répliqué pas d'avant
elle fixera marquise en dépit de tout le
monde si vous mettez donc on lire
cela ferait du chef de faire des poids
pour âge encore suivez moi ma fille est
venue du résolument votre père que si
vous ne l'avez vous ne voulez pousser
personnes vous avez fait de belles
affaires avec vos bons sentiments que
veux tu j'ai un scrupule là dessus que
l'exemple ne serez vaincus vous moquez
vous de le prendre sérieusement avec un
homme comme cela ne voyez vous pas qu'il
est fou et vous coûte et il quelque
chose de vous accorder à ces fumeurs
raison mais je ne croyais pas qu'il
fallut faire ses preuves de noblesse
pour être gendre de monsieur jourdain de
coire et eu une pensée qui me vient pour
jouer notre âme et vous faire obtenir ce
que vous souhaitez également l'idée tout
à fait plaisante quoi dont cp de plus
peu une certaine mascarade qui vient le
mieux du monde ici et que je prétends
fait rentrer dans une bourde que je vais
faire à notre ridicule tout cela semble
sa comédie mais avec les emplois hasard
d autres choses ni pourquoi chercher
tant de façons il est a mal joué son
rôle à merveille à 2 les aimants dans
toutes lés paris balcon s'avisera lui
dire j'ai les acteurs je les habille
tout près laissez moi faire seulement à
prendre moi je vais vous instruire
détour que diable et cela ils n'ont rien
que les grands seigneurs à me reprocher
et moi je ne vois rien de si beau que de
rentes et les grands seigneurs et demi à
connaître les possibilités avec eux je
voudrais qu'ils m'écoutent et deux
doigts de la main il est rené contre
marck monsieur voici monsieur le comte
et une dame qui le mène par l'ama j'ai
quelques endroits donnés dès lors que je
vais venir ici tout à l'heure
monsieur dit comme cela qu'il va me dire
ici tout à l'heure voilà qui est bien
je ne sais pas de grandes je fais encore
ici une étrange démarche de me laisser
emmener par vous dans une maison où je
ne connais personne quels lieux
voulez-vous dont madame comme en avion
choisissent pour vous régaler puisque
pour furet l'éclat vous ne voulait ni
votre maison o'neill à mieux mais vous
ne dites pas que je m'engage
insensiblement chaque jour à recevoir de
trop grand témoignage de votre passion
j'ai beau me défendre des choses vous
fatigué ma résistance et vous avez une
civile opiniâtreté qui me fait revenir
doucement à tout ce qui vous plaît
les visites fréquentes commencer les
déclarations sont venus ensuite qui
après celle entraînée les sérénades les
cadeaux que les présents ont suivi je me
suis opposé à tout cela ne vous rebute
épreuve et puis à pied vous gagnez les
résolutions pour moi je ne fais plus
répondre de rien et je crois qu'à la fin
vous me feriez venir au mariage donc je
ne suis temps vous veniez ma foi madame
voulzy devriez déjà être vous êtes veuve
et ne dépendez que de vous je suis
maître de moi et vous aime plus que ma
vie à quoi tient t-il que dès
aujourd'hui vous ne fassiez de mon
bonheur mon dieu de rente
il faut des deux par bien des qualités
pour vivre heureusement ensemble et les
deux plus raisonnable personnes du monde
ont souvent peine à composer une union
dont ils soient satisfaits vous madame
de vous y figurent et en difficulté et
que l'expérience que vous avez fait de
conclure rien pour tous les autres enfin
je reviens toujours là les dépenses que
je vous vois faire pour moi m'inquiète
pas de raison l'unique m engage plus que
je ne voudrais et l'autre que je suis
sûr sans vous déplaire que vous ne fait
point que vous de vous un comédien et je
ne veux point cela au madame ce sont des
bagatelles
et ce n'est pas par là je sais ce que je
dis est entre autres le diamant qu'on
avait forcé à prendre d'un prix elle
madame de grâce ne fait pourtant valoir
une chose que mon amour trouve indigne
de vous et souffre et voici le maître du
je suis un peu plus loin madame comment
un pas s'il vous plaît quad ou de
reculer un peu pour la troisième madame
monsieur jourdain c'est son monde
madame se met une gloire bien à grande
de me voir assez fortunés pour être
aussi heureux que d'avoir le bonheur que
vous ayez eu la bonté de m'accorder la
grâce de me faire l'honneur de mme
honoré de la faveur de votre présence
ici j'avais aussi le mérite pour mériter
un mérite comme le vôtre et que le ciel
envieux de mon bien lui accorder
davantage ne peut voir digne des
messieurs jour d'or voilà c'est madame
n'aime pas les grands compliments et
elle sait que vous êtes un homme
d'esprit c'est un bourgeois assez
ridicule que vous voyez dans toutes ces
manuels
et pas mal aisé de s'en apercevoir
madame voilà le meilleur de mes amis
c'est trop d'honneur que vous me faites
galante sommes tout à fait j'ai beaucoup
d'estimé pour lui je n'ai rien fait
encore madame pour mériter cette grâce
pour les biens cadeaux moins que tu
pourras parler du diamant volé avait
donné ne corrige pas seulement lui
demander comment elle le trouve
regardez vous en bien ce serait vivant à
vous et pour agir en galante hommes
il faut vous fassiez comme si ce n'était
pas vous qui devez crs présents monsieur
jourdain madame dit qu'il est ravi de
vous voir chez lui
il meurt beaucoup que je vous suis
obligé monsieur de lui parler ainsi pour
moi j'ai une peine effroyable à la faire
venir ici je ne sais quelle grâce aux
amendes il dit madame il vous trouve la
plus belle personne du monde c'est bien
de la grâce qu'il me fait madame c'est
vous qui faites les grâces et le songe
aux à manger tout est prêt monsieur
alors de lui mettre à table et qu'on
fasse venir les musiciens
[Musique]
non
voilà un repas tout à fait magnifique
mots-clés madame il faudrait qu'il faut
plus que je ne réponds à ce compliment
quand mangeant comme je le fais par deux
voilà de belles
on aimait son métier autre monsieur
jourdain mais vous voulez parler du
diamant dieu me garde en vouloir parler
ce cépage des renc'arts au top et le
diamant il faut peu de choses cette bien
dégoûté
vous avez trop de bons talents qu'on
donne du vin monsieur jourdain et ya ces
messieurs qui nous feront la grave le
chanter un air à voir
c'est merveilleusement a cédé la bonne
chère qui verrait la musique et je me
vois ici admirablement régal madame ce
n'est pas monsieur jourdain havre et en
silence à ces messieurs ce qui nous dire
on verra mieux que de ce que nous
pourrions dire mais bon le temps qui
fuit nous y conduire
harry potter
quand qu'on a passés ont des droits
comme à dieu
dépêchons-nous
[Musique]
les bonheurs de la vie
de fait
ils sont faits
mais pas pour nous mais bien de savoir
si face à bessan des cominois soir des
sans voix
[Musique]
non
ces garçons persévère c'est toujours
quand on vous dit à cbc baisse l'hiver
c'est toujours que je suis tout seul
[Musique]
mais
je crois pas qu'on puisse mieux chanter
et cela est tout à fait bon je vois
encore ici madame quelque chose de plus
beau
ouais monsieur jourdain galant plus que
je ne pensais pas d'amour qui pendent et
vous monsieur jourdain je voudrais bien
à quel mépris pour ce que je dirai
encore vous ne le connaissez pas elle ne
connaîtra quand il lui plaira aux hôtels
qui il est homme qui a toujours la
riposte en main mais vous ne voyez pas
que monsieur jourdain madame mange tous
les morceaux vous touchez monsieur
jourdain est un homme qui me ravit
si je pouvais ravir votre hauteur je
serai je trouve ici pour une compagnie
et je vois bien qu'on ne m'y attendais
pas c'est on possède bel aperçu monsieur
mon mari quand vous avez su tant
d'empressement à m'envoyer dîner chez ma
soeur je viens de voir au théâtre là bas
et je vois ici un banquet à tarnos voilà
comme vous dépensez votre bien et c'est
ainsi que vous fait signer les dames en
mon absence et que vous leur donnez la
musique et la comédie tandis que vous
mourriez promener que voulez-vous dire
madame jourdain et qu'elle fantaisie
sont les vôtres vous allez mettre en
tête que votre mari dépenses sont bien
et que c'est lui qui donne se régalera
dame
apprenez c'est moi je vous prie et qu'il
est facilement que m'a prêté sa maison
et que vous devriez un peu mieux
regarder aux choses que vous dites oui
impertinente
c'est monsieur le comte qui donne tout
ce chien madame qui est une personne de
qualité
il me fait l'honneur de prendre ma
maison est de vouloir que je sois avec
lui deux ans des chansons que ça je sais
ce que je sais problème le joueur
prenait d'un meilleur lunettes
je n'ai que faire de lunettes lesieu je
vois ça c'est clair
il ya longtemps que je sens les choses
et je ne suis pas une bête ce live
formule 1 vous pour un grand seigneur de
prêter la main comme vous faites ou
sortie de mon mari et vous madame pour
une grande havre cela n'est ni poignonec
à vous de mettre de la dissension dans
un ménage et de souffrir que mon mari
soit amoureux de vous tu as tout ceci
allait de rentrer vous me que de
m'exposer aux cette vision de cette
extravagante aux mains d'hommes au laval
en cours et vous madame merkel compte
fait truex que j'ai tâché de leur avenir
pertinente que vous avez voilà vos bons
frais vous venez faire d amour devant
tout le monde et vous savez que c'est
moi des personnes de qualité knocked
leurs qualités jeunes qui revendiquent
que je ne peux prendre la tête avec les
pierres du repas que vous n'êtes plus
troublé je me mentais cela ce sont mes
trois que je défends et je réponds moi
toutes les femmes vous faites bien
vérité ma colère elle est arrivée lundi
est malheureusement les rendements de
lire de jolies choses et jamais je ne
m'étais senti quand d'esprit qu'est ce
que c'est kossmann
[Musique]
mais si je ne sais pas si j'ai l'honneur
d'être reconnus des vous non monsieur
si vous avez vu que vous n'étiez pas
plus grave que cela moi oui mais c'est
une des plus belles enfants du monde et
toutes les dames vous prenez dans leurs
bras pour vos baisers pour me baiser
oui j'ai dû grand ami de fumée sur votre
père de feu monsieur mon père oui si tu
t'es fort honnête gentilhomme comment
dites-vous
j'ai dit que c'était un effort honnête
chantillon mon père oui mais il faut
reconnu assurément
et vous l'avez connu pour gentilhomme
sans doute je ne sais donc pas comment
le monde et fait commun il y à deux
sauts de gens qui me veulent dire qu il
a été marcher lui malchance c'est plus
le met dix ans et ne l'a jamais été
tout ce qu'il faisait ce qu'il était
fort obligeant provisions comme ils se
connaissaient pas bien l'année d'offres
il allait choisir de tous les côtés il
peut apporter chez lui et on donne est à
ses amis pour de l'argent je suis ravi
de vous connaître afin que vous rendiez
ce témoignage là que mon père était
gentille homme chéri soutiendrait des 23
est morte m'obligerait quels sujets vous
amène des puits avait reconnu que
monsieur votre père on est gentil comme
je vous ai dit j'ai voyagé partout le
monde par tout le monde
je pense qu'il ya bien longtemps dans ce
pays là assurément
génisses u devenu de tous mes longs
voyages que depuis quatre jours et par
l'intérêt que je prends à tout ce qui
vous touche je viens vous annoncer la
meilleure nouvelle du mot qu'elle vous
savez que le fils du grand turc est ici
moi non
comment il est en train tout à fait
magnifique tout le monde ne pas avoir
été reçus en ce pays comme un seigneur
d'importance une part ma foi je ne
savais pas cela c'est qu'il ya davantage
que pour vous c'est qu'il est amoureux
de votre fille
le puy du grand turc oui il veut être
votre jambe
mon gendre le fils du grand tueur le
fils du grand turc que votre job comme
je le suis et que je m'entends
parfaitement sa langue il s'apprête avec
moi
après quelques les autres discours il me
dit assia mme coxon un uche à la
moustache s'agit de l'homme manaev al
aini ussel relate c'est à dire la tue
point vu une jeune belle personne qui la
fille de monsieur jourdain gentilhomme
parisien le fils du grand tueur dit cela
de moi oui comme je lui ai répondu que
je vous connaissez particulièrement et
que j'avais vu votre fille
on me dit il mara baba sall c'est à dire
que je suis amoureux d'elle mara bavasse
am veut dire que je suis amoureux d'elle
oui par mme affret vous faites bien de
me le dire car pour moi je n'aurais
jamais cru que ce marhaba base à m
il vous le dira que je suis amoureux
d'elle voilà une langue admirable que ce
tueur guillou plus admirable qu'on ne
peut quoi
savez-vous bien ce que veut dire qu à
callac hammouche m
qu'un quart à cannes ou faible non c'est
à dire ma chère à mme k karaka mouche
1-2 veux dire ma chaire ah oui voilà qui
est merveilleux très carakan j'aime ma
chère à me dire et on jamais seul voilà
qui me confond enfin pour la suite mon
ambassade
il vient vous demander votre fille en
mariage et pour avoir un bon père qui
soit digne de lui
il va vous faire mamamouchi qui est une
certain grande dignité de son pays même
hammouchi oui maman bougies c'est à dire
en notre langue
paladin pas la danse
ce sont de ces anciens d'ad dauphin n'y
a rien de plus noble que cela dans le
monde et vous irez dupel avec les plus
grands seigneurs de la terre
le fils de grand turk moenner beaucoup
et je vous prie de le mener chez nuit on
veut en faire mes remerciements comment
mais le voilà qui va venir ici il va
venir ici
oui et il amène toute chose pour la
cérémonie des votre dignité
voilà qui est bien trop
son amour ne peut souffrir au caire
retardement tous ceux qui m'embarrasse
souci c'est que ma fille est une
opiniâtre qui s'étale et mettre en tête
un certain cléonte et elle jure de
l'épousé personne que celui là elle
changera des sentiments quand elle verra
les pistes du grand turc
ils se rencontrent ici une aventure
merveilleuse c'est que le fils du grand
turc ressemble à ses clientes à peu de
choses près je viens de le voir on met
la montée et l'amour que le problème
pour la passe aisément à l'autre je
n'entends venir les voilà au
[Musique]
vert
non
je
[Musique]
en bout ce imac iborra ordina cela
maliki c'est à dire monsieur jourdain
votre coeur soit toute l'année comme un
rosier fleury samson façon de parler
obligeante de ces pays là je suis très
humble serviteur de son altesse turc
calik alcan boutons ou style moral au
studio quant au mollet qui bat sous une
basse et à la morale il dit que le ciel
vous donne la force et des lions est la
plus dense des seuls pas son altesse
turc m'honore trop et je lui souhaite à
toutes sortes de prospérité on s'habille
n'amène sadok ben ali aura qu'à
programme bellemin
[Applaudissements]
il dit que vous allez vite avec nous
préparer pour la cérémonie afin de voir
lance une autre fille était conclure le
mariage quand choses en deux mots oui la
langue turque est comme ça elle dit
beaucoup en peu de paroles aller vite où
il souhaite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
contre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
hu
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
[Musique]
le
anna et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
pas très sport
ça donne ça
pas
saleh
ap
quand on
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
derrick plus tard
non mais
touati
m
atir pâtir
[Musique]
un vote
17h - we started christ anabaptistes
anabaptistes à la baptist
c'est une liste profita aussi
terroristes frau ni saga souterraine de
la mine à profits zhulin tu as quioc
marc prometteur maffre au métal
[Musique]
comment ça marche comment ça marche
comme ça m'a dit c'est moi
[Musique]
matile mâconnais
ah merde c'est fabu maladie
m
[Musique]
d'al khobar
[Applaudissements]
des femmes gagnent
oui oui
antilles
[Musique]
palestine
à
mais voilà
[Musique]
djoudi
[Rires]
[Musique]
oui
e
[Musique]
elle a du mal à me droit sous la halle
jordi nasa la mallet qui captent à
malley kimba samba sera la mort à
moussavi n'a même à la finale
[Musique]
jacques l'hôtel à mayotte brütal legend
branly nama from et arras où la
palestine mahmoud chiche à blagnac pour
fanta la finale aura medrad seul
moustapha petit d'homme à manas comme ça
comme ça la finale a et b
au dim par son nom et sa femme n'ont pas
donné à tout va comme un gant jaune à
dubaï
[Musique]
papa
la paix les âmes ça
la peña lou
[Musique]
il y en
le temps
vous
[Musique]
faux
et
ans
il
[Musique]
paris non qu'est ce que c'est que
ceux-ci qui vous a présenté comme cela
voyez l'impertinente de parler de la
sorte un mamamouchi commandons oui il me
faut porter du respect maintenant et
l'on vient de me faire ma ma mushi
voulez vous dire avec votre mamamouchi
mamamouchi vous dijon je suis mamamouchi
lequel bette et cela même abouchi c'est
à dire en notre langue pas là d'un bon
lot
êtes vous en âge de danse et des ballets
qu'elle ignorante jeudi pallade c'est
une dignité dont on vient de me faire la
cérémonie
quelle cérémonie dont mam et à vergio
redire
jordin c'est-à-dire jourdain et bien
quoi jours d'un voleur farine paladyne
adepte jordi comment nature bande tacos
galère qui ce à dire cela vers
défendeurs palestine
que voulez-vous dire dare dare à
bastonner raison que ce jargon la note
est au top
au fond qu'est ce que c'est donc tout
cela à la balade jours à tout lancement
du marié devenu fou paix insolente
porter respect monsieur le mama mouche
oulala touristes on qu'il a perdu
l'esprit pour l'empêcher de sortir
oh c'est justement le reste de notre vie
je ne vois que chagrin de tous les côtés
[Applaudissements]
vous verrez la plus plaisante chose
qu'on puisse voir et je ne crois pas que
dans tout le monde ils soient pas si
d'autres vire encore un homme aussi fou
c'est le monde là et puis madame il faut
tâcher de servir l'amour de clientèle et
d'appuyer toute sa mascarade les infos
40 hommes et qui mérite que l'on
s'intéresse pour lui j'en fais beaucoup
de cas il est digne d'une bonne fortune
outre cela nous avons ici madame un
ballet qui nous revient que ne devons
pas laisser perdre et il faut bien voir
si mon idée pourra réussir
j'ai vu là des attraits magnifique et ce
sont des choses de rands que je ne paie
pu souffrir que oui je veux enfin vous
empêcher vos professions et pour rompre
le cours à toutes les dépenses que je
vous vois faire pour moi j'ai résolu de
me marier contre mantes avec vous c'en
est le vrai secret et toutes ces choses
finissent avec le mariage homo d'hommes
est il possible que vous ayez pu prendre
pour vous empêcher de bourriner sans
cela je dois bien qu'avant tu peux vous
n'auriez pas un sou je suis
d'obligations madame aux fins que vous
avez les conserver mon bien il est
entièrement temps joue aussi bien gros
coeur et vous enlevez de la phase 1
je serai bien de piloter et voici votre
en la figure en est admirable monsieur
nous venons rendre hommage madame et moi
votre nouvelle dignité et nous réjouir
avec vous du mariage que vous faites de
votre fille avec le fils du grand tueur
monsieur je vous souhaite la force des
serpents et l'imprudence des religions
j'ai été bien des êtres des premières
monsieur à venir vous féliciter du haut
degré de gloire et beauté
madame 1 je vous souhaite tout caler
votre rosier fleuve je vous suis
infiniment obligé de prendre part aux
honneurs qui m'arrive et j'ai beaucoup
de joie de vous voir revenu ici pour
vous faire les trésors nous excusent de
l'extravagance de ma faim cela n'est
rien
j'excuse en l appareil mouvement votre
coeur notre précieux et il n'est pas
étrange que la possession d'un homme
comme vous puisse inspirer quelques
années la position de mon coeur est une
chose qui vous et tout acquises vous
voyez madame que monsieur journal ait
pas de ces gens que les prospérité
aveugle et qu'il sait dans sa gloire
connaître encore ses amis si la marque
d'une âme ou et dont son altesse turc
nous voudrions bien comme vos amis de
lui rendre nos devoirs
voilà qui vire et j'ai envoyé quérir ma
fille pour lui donner la mort monsieur
nous voulons faire la révérence votre
altesse comme amis de monsieur votre
beau-père et l'assuré avec respect de
l'autre est humble service
où est le truchement pour lui dire que
vous êtes élu faire entendre ce que vous
dites vous verrez qu il vous répondra il
parle turcs amers magna aulas ou des
autres et ils allaient se trouve ce
tarif prof drap
monsieur étant un grand des seniors
grandi seniors grand des seniors dames 1
une grande adama grandadam à ayette lui
monsieur lui mamouzi français et madame
un ma bouche il français je ne suis pas
parler plus clairement
bon voici l'interprète waliboo dont nous
ferions rien dire sans vous
fils lui un peu de monsieur et madame
sont des personnes de grande qualité qui
lui viennent faire la révérence comme
des amis et l'assurer de leur service
vous allez voir comme il va répondre à
la balle un club siamak sibra malabat
mène à tanner qui est aux ballerines
sauter amalou chat voyez-vous il dit
qu'il a plu déplu spirit et arrosant
tout temps les jardins de votre famille
vous l'avait bien dit qu'il parle turc
est admirable mais pas fier approchez
vous venez donner votre main monsieur
qui vous fait l'honneur de vous demander
en mariage faite et c'est une comédie
qu'on joue et non non ce n'est pas une
comédie c'est une affaire font sérieuse
et la plus pleine d'honneur pour vous
qui ça peut souhaiter
voilà le mari que je vous en dis à moi
mon père oui avoue à l'eau tout chez lui
dans la main et rendez grâce au ciel de
votre bonheur ne veux pas me marier je
le feu mois qui suivent votre père salo
ferait rien que de bruits allons vous
dis-je ça votre main non mon père je
voulais dit il n'est pas le pouvoir
qu'ils me plus obligés à prendre à
l'autre mary que cléonte et je me
résoudrai plutôt à toutes les extrémités
que il est vain que vous êtes mon père
et que je vous dois entière obéissance
c'est à vous à disposer de moi
selon-vous volonté je suis ravi de vous
voir si promptement revenu dans votre
devoir et voilà qui me plaît d'avoir une
fille obéissante
on dit que vous voulez donner votre
fille en mariage un karen prenant où les
voix outre impertinente venez toujours
mais les veaux extravagance qu'à toute
chose il n'y a pas moyen de vous
apprendre et raisonnable
c'est vous qui n'y a pas moyen de rendre
sage et vous allez de folie une folie
quel est votre destin et que voulez vous
faire avec cet assemblage
je veux me marier notre fille avec le
fils du grand turc avec le fils du grand
turc
oui vous pouvez faire vos compliments
par le truchement que voilà je ne peux
faire de truchement et je lui dirai bien
moi-même aston
et qui n'aura pas ma fille voulez-vous
très encore une fois comment madame
jourdain
vous vous opposez un honneur comme
celui-là vous refusez son altesse turc
pour gendron que monsieur mail et vous
de vos affaires
c'est une grande gloire qui n'est pas à
rejeter madame je vous prie aussi de ne
vous pas être embarrassé de ce qui ne me
touche pas c'est l'amitié que des avants
pour vous qui lui fait intéressé dans
vos avantages je me passerais bien de
votre amitié voilà votre fille qui
consorts volonté de son père la fille
consent à épouser un turc sans doute
elle peut tout blier créons ce que ne
fait on pas pour être grande dame je
voulais trempent leur aide mais mal si
elle n'avait pas un coup comme celui là
voilà bien du cacqueray je vous dis que
ce mariage l'un se fera je vous dis moi
qui ne se fera point alors que de bruit
c'est une copine mois voilà que rené de
ce qu'est le mobi oui elle est à moi
aussi bien qu'à madame comme vous voulez
vous comptez vous un mot je n'ai que
faire de votre mot messieurs si elle
veut écouter une parole en particulier
je vous promets de la paire consentir à
ceux qui vous voulez je n'y consentirait
points écoutez moi seulement n'ont
écouté non je ne veux pas écouté il vous
dira je ne veux point qu'il me dise rien
voilà une grande obstination de femmes
cela vous fera t-il mal de l'entente
n'est fait qu'elle écoute et vous
paierez après ce qu'il vous plaira eh
bien quoi
il ya une heure madame que nous vous
faisons signe ne voyez vous pas bien que
tout ceci n'était que pour nous ajuster
aux visions de votre mari que nous
l'accusons sous ce déguisement et que
ses clientes lui même qui est le fils du
grand turc et moi covial qui suit le
truchement comme cela je me rends pour
tous ne fait pas semblant de rien voilà
qui est fait
je consens au mariage ah voilà tout le
monde raisonnable vous ne vouliez pas
l'écouter je savais bien qu'il vous
expliquerai ce que c'est que le fils du
grand tueur il me l'a expliqué comme il
faut et j'en suis satisfaite en voyant
quérir un notaire s'est fort bien dit et
afin madame jourdain que vous puissiez
avoir l'esprit tout à fait content et
que vous perdiez d'aujourd'hui toute la
jalousie que vous pourriez avoir conçu
de monsieur votre mari
c'est que nous servirons dumas notaire
pour nous marier madame et moi je
consens aussi est ce là c'est pour lui
faire à quoi il faut bien la musique
avec cette fin du monde on a église
quérir l'ona taille mais tandis qu'il
viendra qui dresse à les contrats le
voyons notre ballet et de nos
divertissements son altesse turc
ces fortes avisé allons prendre nos
places et nicole cela donne un autre
chemin et ma femme à qui la voudra mais
si je vous remercie
sinon on peut voir un plus fous je lirai
dire à rome
[Musique]
plus
il
[Musique]
je veux tout
des motos
[Musique]
où
et
l'epr
oh
[Musique]
non
m
elle vous
je l'aimé
[Applaudissements]
et
il
[Musique]